[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture au programme une
interview très complices de l'humour ou
encore de la musique électronique
on voit ça en détail dans le sommaire
rencontre dans cette émission avec la
chanteuse juliette armanet son père jean
pire arman est originaire du pet qu'ils
donneront un concert le 6 décembre dans
leur ville concert intitulé voyage
américain ne nous prendront la direction
du tec à plaisir sa directrice florence
k - vous présentera un de ses prochains
spectacles coup de coeur il s'agit de
gap father le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bientôt
transformé en tant que de la musique
électronique une soirée 100% d'obstacles
est programmée le 7 décembre prochain
plus de 5000 personnes sont attendues un
voyage américain à travers les musiques
de dvorak bernstein ou encore
jean-pierre harman et c'est ce qui vous
attend le 6 décembre prochain au pecq l'
orchestre hexagone interprétera
notamment d'autres créations de l'alpi
couach empire armes année et pour ouvrir
ce concert à sa fille qui n'est autre
que l'auteur compositeur et interprète
juliette armanet lauréate des victoires
de la musique en 2018
en pleine préparation de son deuxième
album elle a accepté de répondre aux
questions en de mélanie poker aux côtés
de son père
[Musique]
donc c'est mon père jean piat man et je
sais pas trop quel âge tu as oublié ma
fille compositrice également chanteuse
claviériste et
personne n'a été hors du commun mais
c'est pas la ville de mon enfance mais
j'y suis déjà depuis tellement longtemps
que c'est un peu tout comme finalement
c'est une ville avec un poids affectif
très fort parce que j ai élevé mes
enfants et le pecq c'est une ville
traversée par la scène et par les
péniches et pour moi c'est toujours ici
très important le tfc la ville de nos de
notre enfance c'est là c'est les racines
familiales c'est là où on a grandi où on
a tous grandi ensemble ça va on y
restait 2
je prends une claque du mois peut-être
enfin moi en tout cas j'ai le pecq j'ai
vécu près d'eux un petit peu moins de 20
ans ça c'est la ville de notre enfance
voilà c'est le berceau on va dire le
pecq c'est notre autre berceau
je partage pas la scène je suis invité
sur la scène de robert sa part est une
petite apparition que j'appellerais
plutôt locomotive parce que je pense que
je vais être très grande gentillesse de
me prêter sa réputation pour mon travail
c'est bizarre mais je suis flatté par
une part ma propre fille et s'était pas
fait je suis extrêmement content mais ce
n'est en fin c'était peut-être juste de
retour de chose dans le fond c'est vrai
ça juste retour des choses moi j'ai j'ai
l'impression que dans tous mes accord
dans toutes mes mélodies il ya forcément
forcément c'est parce que tu veux mais
oui tu as mais c'est vrai j'ai regardé
il ya des j'ai entendu la musique de mes
parents et celle de mon père toute mon
enfance et elle est totalement
omniprésente dans mon travail dans mes
mélodies dans mes choix d'accord dans ma
façon de composer
je crois avoir volé et nerveusement
chose il va j'avais eu la délicatesse de
ne jamais me le dire que évidemment il
ya des grilles d'accords qui sont
complètement les médecins ont fait
plaisir de reconnaître quelques fois des
oui non peut-être pas des thèmes et des
des réflexes musicaux et
et quelque part je suis un double au
compositeur parce que j'ai l'impression
que ma fille a su avec le langage de sa
génération transformer mais
balbutiements d'improvisateur au départ
c'est un peu une histoire de famille je
ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai voulu emmener
mes enfants là bas parce que enfants
j'ai rêvé d'aller là bas comme beaucoup
de petits français des années 50 avant
de réfléchir à comment l'histoire de la
mairie s'inscrivait dans l'histoire
mondiale
mais ces perceptions naïve que j'avais
ce besoin de liberté passé par
l'amérique donc mais aussi new york ces
espèces de deal qui flotte un peu dans
le second il y avait un côté aventure
maritime et familiale et pour moi je
sais tu es un des plus beaux voyages de
ma vie parce que j'ai prouvé avec mes
enfants cette sensation de liberté à ses
un indice id on sait pas pourquoi mais
je me suis sentie transporter nous on
est important parce que transporte sur
moi c'est une chose importante qui fait
rêver
donc notre amérique merci l'amérique
voilà chanter comme ça raconté comme ça
l'amérique s'est accusé laventure c'est
la liberté c'est les grands espaces
c'est les gratte ciel qui vont aller
toucher les dieux les cieux c'est la
folie des grandeurs voilà c'est
l'amérique donc donc du coup ouais ça me
semblait bien d'ouvrir d'ouvrir cette
soirée-là sur quelque chose qui me fait
un peu un clin d'oeil à une non une
vieille vision de la mairie vision un
peu naïve et surtout ça me dépasse
sur steam mais en tout cas voilà ses
troupes de la folie des grandeurs jours
que cet impôt devrait l'être
c'est un orchestre qui s'est
professionnalisé assez naturellement
parce que ce sont tous des gens jeunes
d'abord qui vit qui sont en plus des
têtes comme on dit ils viennent tous
deux ils ont tous fait des études
absolument prodigieuse c'est plutôt les
scientifiques d'ailleurs je dirais d'une
façon un petit peu
médiatique c'est un peu la star ac de la
musique classique sont très jeunes etc
des étoiles montantes
[Musique]
le trait
oh
elle aussi est lauréate des victoires de
la musique et jeanne added sera sur la
scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines le vendredi 6
décembre à 20h30
l'occasion de découvrir sa voix si
particulière
[Musique]
ja
non
[Musique]
j
une
à lille
[Musique]
autre rendez vous avec l'idole de toute
une génération le chanteur roch voisine
sera en concert à la lanterne à
rambouillet le samedi 7 décembre à 20h45
il s'agit de sa nouvelle tournée
intitulée rock acoustique solution sable
on rêve était trop beau et qui se
cherche
partir à 100 mais le lieu tout leur
avais la theurre tu me rappelles toi
tout ce temps
m
forest
régulièrement dans cette émission les
directeurs ou directrices
d'établissements culturels de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines nous
présentent leur coup de coeur je vous
propose de prendre la direction du tec à
plaisir avec sa directrice florence k
monde les gags father c'est le 6
décembre à 20h30 c'est une compagnie
espagnole je vous garantis que les
espagnols se sont des dingues et que si
vous voulez retrouver un esprit mais
alors si on parle des british ce sera
béni il
il ya plein de références c'est un peu
du charlie chaplin c'est un peu du
mesnil cetc du mime cd dingue
il faut absolument les découvrir pour
passer une soirée totalement hilarant
hilarante je pense que leur retour vous
aurez mal à la mâchoire tellement vous
aurait rigolé
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est
du théâtre avec elle la pièce le prénom
qui sera joué sur la scène de la ferme
du mané le dimanche le 8 décembre à 17
heures parmi les têtes d'affiché pour
cette version
les humoristes florent peyre et jonathan
lambert tu veux pas savoir comment il a
pu nager ou pas
[Musique]
vivement le reprendre décidément mon
mari est irrésistible ce soir
moi je les sens des mots et que reporter
méchant mertz à peine 10 comme je me
sens je suis désolé mais je n'ai pas de
cours de prénoms rosoirs de quelqu'un
qui a fait les enfants voilà avertis
elle des peintures des sculptures
jusqu'au 1er décembre nadine michon
investi à la maison félix à montigny le
bretonneux avec ses oeuvres figuratives
ou encore abstraite pour ses peintures
l'artiste utilise de l'huile de
l'aquarelle ou encore de l'acrylique
cette exposition est aussi l'occasion de
découvrir des photographies de jacques
michon je souhaite que le visiteur à la
sortie donc de cette exposition
eh ben il est je dirais du bonheur ils
ressentent disons du repos il ressent
donc accueilli pense sont pratiquement à
des choses agréables tout en ayant
oublié tous ces soucis
en parcourant l'exposition le centenaire
noire se poursuit dans les yvelines le 3
décembre 2019 date du centenaire de la
mort du célèbre artiste peintre un
spectacle musical et littéraire est
organisée à l'auditorium chan aurier à
croissy sur seine
ce sera à 20h30 on va complètement
changer d'univers avec le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines qui
accueillera le 7 décembre prochain une
soirée de dubstep l'événement s'appelle
ambassades il s'agit de l'une des plus
grosses soirées française consacrée à ce
genre de musique électronique assez le
label français 193 ritorte qui organise
cette manifestation où plus de 5000
spectateurs sont attendus
on va avoir son boy donc qui est très
très connu dans le milieu
space les 6000 nay tyrannosaurus must
die bad clac autres prophètes et 30 pas
ensuite on sera aussi accompagné de tout
là l'équipe de français qui tourne très
bien en ce moment à paris et qui
commence vraiment à émerger dans le but
est justement saito sherkan futur et
blue da les gens de la cnds musique
ils ont certes un gros événement ici en
europe mais on n'a pas beaucoup par
rapport à ce qui se passe aux etats-unis
aucun d'un ton tout le monde est sur son
téléphone hagards les vidéos les photos
c'est un truc de fou
nous on aimerait bien voir ça ici en
france donc c'est ça le pari qu'on a
pris avec mon équipe on s'est dit ok
lesbos cette fois on va essayer de créer
ce que tout le monde voit à l'étranger
ici
[Musique]
à
voilà c'est la fin de ce set 8 cultura
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]